[Music]
is this what you wanted to get is oh my
god if you guys can tell I'm a little
bit greasy and the reason why I'm a
little bit greasy is because I just got
done cooking something that's very
special and dear to me
in today's mukbang we are going to be
eating and cooking kimchi fried rice now
this is going to be the typical kimchi
fried rice that you always see I
actually learned how to do this and I
modified it to my own preference from
the sky Stevie it was used to be a part
of this group called Little Miss LA now
I love eating kimchi fried rice my whole
life and I'm pretty sure every Korean
American kid has now typically when you
see like kimchi fried rice you'll see
spam in it and knowledge of [ __ ] this
one's going to be a little different a
little lip smacking Lee a dick skin
delicious
the other day I don't understand why you
guys want to see me eat or eat with me
but if we're sharing a meal together
that's what it's about
and let's talk about this dish how I
made it and why it's so damn delicious
this right here my friends is the
ultimate kimchi fry right now before we
go ahead and dig into this let's talk
about some of the ingredients that we
have in this right here is probably if
you guys haven't had before if you don't
know what that is is actually shiso leaf
it you've had a lot in a lot of Japanese
cooking we of course how to do it in
with the crispy pork belly we had to add
our little ceiling right here on the
side and we did our shredded up green
onions which I personally love and right
smack dab in the middle of my friends is
something that you guys know as a
poached mother [ __ ] pig
whoa I burped now this right here my
friends is the peach that registan this
is going to be a crisped up piece of
sous-vide pork belly
now with the pork belly I actually made
it the night before and when I made the
night before I chilled it and I pressed
it down with the cast iron pan that you
see right here so I made it into a
little bit of a really hard break and I
finished it off in the oven this morning
to make it crispy and then 20 and
so let's go ahead and give that a go oh
you see that oh my god oh man
alright bedroom there's something about
tender crispy pork belly it just does it
for you you know they do you hear that
crunch oh my god
David David so we're going to take this
yoke and I got to make sure I do this
real quick for you guys because you know
Wow yes blough yes
Wow yes yes yes yes like I'm [ __ ]
somebody a sous vide egg is very
interesting because when you soupy it I
want one 45 and you kind of let it cool
down B the angle becomes like a jammy
consistency so you just take a little
bit of the jammy aid mix it with
whatever vegetation that you like and
notice how big this [ __ ] students
take that kimchi fried rice on the
bottom at like so just add a little bit
of that green onion there too and
mm-hmm-hmm
oh yeah now some of you might think what
I'm eating this like yo you should
probably need a little more pork belly
because there's other people that are
going to be eating this well guess what
the kimchi fried rice already has died
stuffed pork belly on the inside now
most people when they make this kimchi
fried rice you'll see it typically done
with spam I personally love spam there's
nothing wrong with it but for me I kind
of wanted to take it up the next level
so the cooking oil that I use for this
in particular isn't actually cooking oil
it's actually the fat from the pork
belly that I cooked before I do the
ricin and what you do with that is that
you render out all the fat can you make
the pork belly extra crispy now a lot of
people when they do this they tend to
jump the gun they see that the pork is
cooked it's brown they're pretty much
done with it but you don't want it to be
a pale brown you want it to be nice and
crispy because you need to measure all
that fat and you want that that
delicious like crunchy little pork treat
inside oh my god
[Music]
look at that ministry there's something
better
we'd like her to have like you I see me
before dried seaweed is awesome because
ads like this birthday flavor to your
stuff if you don't like free weave I
understand but don't don't don't fray
away from this stuff too because it
seems it also has msg so mission food
tastes really good now someone you might
be asking you know why do I believe the
cast iron pampers or why am i cooking
this in the cast iron pan well with
risen will put this is the piece de
resistance
I think that's friends I don't know what
that means but I think it translates to
that bomb is [ __ ] now
this bottom crispy joint right here is
my favorite favorite part of cooking
kimchi fried rice or any fight rice or
the cast iron pen a lot of Asian people
know this but back in the day like armor
like people would fight to have this
part to like that burnt rice bottoms if
you get but imagine this burnt rice
bottom mixed with pork fat and roasted
kimchi juices and that's what you get oh
I'll typically to what you'll see when
people make kimchi fried rice soup they
just like to throw the kimchi right into
the rice I don't do that I actually put
it into the cooked pork belly because
I'm actually making a second dish with
in is kimchi fried rice called kimchi
tail poking so this dish actually has a
couple of components that most people
might be surprised when people do kimchi
fried radish like they'll just throw
kimchi and the juices into the rice well
before you do that and before I do that
I actually put it into the pork belly
and the reason why is because that pork
fat is going to melt with that briny
delicious like fermented kimchi and it's
going to soak into it and on top of that
with the heat that'll row so actually
give it like another like level or depth
of flavor
it's so good seems like
stick-to-your-ribs type of food we're
gonna dig into the pork belly again of
course
per usual dip it into the Jana yoke
right get it into the jammy Oh
some of the favorite foods I like to
make are the foods that I ate growing up
the reason why is the food is very
important to me I think that badass I'd
like to stuff food in his face you know
sitting around and sharing a meal when
people have kind of disappeared it's all
about fast food and like making food
quick and were tuned as well there was a
culture that came with eating food you
know it was it's kind of like how people
used to bond and I miss that and one of
the biggest reasons why I'm such an
advocate of people making food is
because it makes you appreciate your
food a lot more - you know there's a lot
of people in like this Yelp culture this
Yelp elite culture will to go on
they like the - as a restaurants about
the foods that they make and they want
to critique what they're doing but the
funny thing is if you give that same
person who was such a connoisseur being
a chef a knife a cutting board and a pen
they want to know what the [ __ ] to do
with this so my personal pain is like if
you can't cook you don't really have
much of an opinion on how cool should be
made what's good
you know another bigger reason why I
love blue is because my mom is such a
great cook and I was very blessed to
have a mother who despite the fact that
she worked 80 plus hours a week you know
she helped my dad at the church that we
were attending cooking food every Sunday
so mind you she was working at the store
I think for my 8:00 a.m. to like 8:00
p.m. when I was younger and that's
Monday to Saturday and then on Sunday
she would or a Saturday night she would
come home and like make sandwiches and
like pack up all these drinks for Sunday
school for the kids and after that she
would make the church come food and
that's just the type of mom that I have
which is why food is very important to
be because food is honestly love you
know a lot of times people they don't
get it especially an Asian Center
they'll say stuff like oh I don't hear
your parents say I love you well I'll
tell you where love is man love is in
this kimchi fried rice
[Music]
hmm oh yeah the drink that I'm going to
pair this delicious salty goodness with
it isn't like my ability beer and
remember back the days that I didn't
like beer which was absolutely true I
used to [ __ ] hate it I thought it was
piss water but I think about me getting
older I don't know look like here your
taste buds change with your palate
changes but I actually do like one good
beer let's pop this bad boy open stop
what Oh Cheers
[Music]
and that's that taste right that day too
sweet I don't know why what happened
what happened to when you're older what
we have here is a different type of 2g I
like to eat visiting team with this
fried rice because this price is so
decadent and it already has a spicy
kimchi inside I want to eat it with
something a little more lightning
refreshing and this is what this white
kimchi is so it kind of like kimchi with
more liquid and no nose chili pepper or
you could drink the brining liquid and
we should call the Adhan chopsticks
where this you of course I can just eat
this straight up mm-hmm
love you're wondering why am i eating
straight out of this boot mine nobody
out for a bit money No
you close another piece of pork belly
bottom cap down crunchy top listen forth
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
now when you're making kimchi fried rice
there's something very important that
you should know it's the type of kimchi
that you use some you will go into these
American stores and you'll see kimchi
and it looks a little bright I
understand all the way read through you
don't want to use that kimchi and the
reason why is because really prevented
kimchi has to be use with pride rice or
even stews because that flavor is
permeated throughout the whole cabbage
and you need those juices and that
flavor to go into this rice to even
color it correctly but what kind of food
that you guys go with what I'm wondering
from Lee dishes one of my dishes that
really really kind of like hit the spot
for me but if you're not a Korean
American out there I kind of wonder like
what do you wait you will funny enough I
remember when I was a kid I just loved
my mom's like kimchi fried rice it was
like the best thing in the world to me I
wanted to get all the time and
specifically this one day I had you know
my I would eat lunch at school my mom
would give me a couple of us to violet
sandwich something and instead of doing
that right decide to pack away fight
kimchi fried rice and put it into a
lunchbox and I remember my dad stopped
me and he told me that I shouldn't do
that mask my nose because like he said
you might get made fun of no it smells
and people aren't going to want that
around and for me I didn't understand it
I understand that why people thought my
food smelled or why people make fun of
me because of the food that I eat
because it's just something that I
really enjoyed and I kind of got it
because I remember one time in school
this other kid he brought like chow mein
over and uh but like you know we didn't
have too many like white kids in our
school but the few that were there and
they kind of clown on them saying like
oh my god what are you eating like worms
or [ __ ] and I'm not it's weird
you know how people can kind of like
make fun of you based on the food that
you eat that you enjoy because it's
foreign to them but we kind of live in a
world now where you know we're a little
bit more culturally the Internet has
allowed us to understand food a little
more so the kid brings fried rice to
school I'm pretty sure all the light
kids are like yeah okay get some but
it's you know but when I was a kid we
were kind of like taught to be a little
bit ashamed of the food that we ate
just because other people didn't
understand it and ignorance in that kind
of sense is something that hurts us the
most they didn't know the botanist it
keeps you fried rice and how if I'm in
LA and there's like a white guy walking
up to me like hey you know what kimchi
is bro my [ __ ] do you know what ugh
what the [ __ ] don't see me walking up to
you asking what a [ __ ] hamburger is
oh here it is the best piece right there
God you know in between these pork belly
is so good because the bottom part is
very median steak like and the middle
part has like this creamy delicious fat
and then you get the nice delicious
texture or crunchy texture from the pork
skin once you boil it under the other
this looks like the smudge on my head
it's not as smudge is actually a bruise
from when I had a high B in my arm when
I got back surgery not too long ago um
but you know before I started doing
these videos
I actually researched a couple of people
who doing multiple men most bucks are
cracking me up because I thought some
people just kind of do some like
ridiculous exaggerated [ __ ] I notice a
guy eating a piece of bread like it was
the most delicious thing he's ever eaten
his life and I was like [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of here that's white bread this
[ __ ] said oh oh my god oh my god
it's bragging my god
no one food is really good
you kind of don't know when to stop
eating it
and that's my biggest problem like if I
don't act the food that I'm eating
I know automatically helpful item I
might ask I don't really need a bite of
this I'm pretty full but when you really
really like the dish you can't stop
there's like you get possessed by like
the Cookie Monster assumption on them in
the month
oh I'm getting damp oh I'm almost there
this has to be like close to 3,500
college maybe 5,000 calories 3,500 5,000
or two big different double tees dumbass
al Qaeda good day I still don't know how
you look for ingrowth it always got
their food still it make sense to me
they just like sitting from the camera
oh I'm not really other food oh no then
some people come up
Moctezuma da I know I'm gonna probably
like taking pounds of food I'm telling
you right now their duty is crazy
your pork belly reminds me of some pork
belly reminds me of Filipinos I actually
fell in love with eating pork belly in
the reason why I added it to this dish
was because I personally loved um
Filipino lechon next one is one of the
best ways to eat pork on the Spurs my
god I'll tell you something dude
Filipino people know how to import right
yeah my first have that tornado I am
Filipino family party and if you
Filipino you know goes up a family party
you [ __ ] celebrate everything
for no goddamn reason what are we
celebrating today oh you didn't hear
John Apollo just farted today I'm sorry
I'm at the tapout I can't do this it's
too much food
I'm surprised I think this much in the
first place so I hope you like life is
much fun hope you like the UH the new
rendition where I kind of cuz I don't
really teach you how to make it because
I don't really have time to set it up
like that but I did give you guys a
little bit of insight on how to make
this at home
remember cook your food
and I'll hope you'll gain perspective on
the food that you read especially when
you go out also to save you money and to
help eliminate food waste so just let me
know in the comments below what else you
guys want me to make if you guys want me
to do another month bottom two the
second one the first one did really well
and you guys want to see more of like
hey I'm going to make this food anyway
so I might as well just record it so let
me know y'all love you to death I sell
them to stop eating my coupon this one
time I when the food is good you can't
stop
[Music]